last week conflict zone put the
spotlight on Britain's fast approaching
EU referendum and we talked to the leaf
campaign this week it's the turn of
those who want to remain in the EU and
one of their leading supporters the
Labour MP Stephen Kinnick why does he
believe that leaving the EU would be a
betrayal of British values
Stephen Kenneth welcome to conflict zone
thank you a nervous time for you coming
up to the referendum so nervous that you
even started to talk about what it would
be like to lose haven't you well what I
was actually trying to do was say that
the leave campaign has made no attempt
at all to describe what a post Drex at
UK would look like so the question I was
raising was if we were to vote to leave
which are clearly hope that we weren't
what would the mandate be because
there's a huge difference between
staying in the single market or leaving
it but why res Latinos you sense defeat
no I'm raising it now because I think
it's really important that when people
go to the ballot box on the twenty-third
of June they understand what leave means
and at the moment there's a black hole
where but there was no questions even if
they vote leave they know what they
don't want they don't want free movement
they don't want to massive contributions
to the EU and they don't want to be
governed by laws made in Brussels do
that precise that'll be quite clear what
they don't want precisely the point that
if you and you want to water that don't
know I what I'm saying is if the option
on the table is to stay in the single
market like Norway is not an EU but in
the single market you have to accept
free movement of people and you have to
pay into the EU they don't want that is
that what I wanna do that the leaf
campaign though is it isn't it well I
the last I looked they had 23 different
models that they've proposed they have
they have not that in a matter in my
view they've deliberately not defined
what model did you raise the prospect of
watering down the will of the British
people and that's a serious thing to do
isn't it the question I'm asking is when
people vote leave on the twenty-third of
June what are they actually voting for
in or out of the single market and as we
don't have an answer to that question if
we do vote leave where does that leave
Parliament after the 23rd because the
debate will be what sort of deal do we
do with the EU with the remaining 27
member states but there won't be a clear
mandate if the e if the leaf campaign
had said from the beginning right we
want to stay in the single market but we
want out of the EU okay that would be
clear or there was if they'd said from
the beginning about we want out we want
the Canada model but why raise this now
why is this now cuz
suggests that you want to tamper with
the result if it doesn't go the way you
want you're leaving that possibility you
will try to dilute the will of the
people not at all the reason I'm raising
it is to draw it isn't worried no it to
draw attention to the fact that the
leave campaign is actually presenting a
non choice to the British people because
it's it's leave but underneath leave
there are so many different questions
and none of those have been answered if
we leave Margot simple process well but
the vote the vote is is going to be
quite clear one way or the other isn't
it we have the biggest choice that's
faced this country for generations on
the twenty-third of June and people are
going into those ballot boxes without
any clarity at all on what leave looks
like and I think that that is a major
question for our democracy it's it's a
hard sell the you isn't it these days
European Union is waning in influence
medals far too much in the affairs of
the constituent members a union that
fails to respect individual governments
that's a hard cells I've been what is
that too bleak and assessment for you
I've been a member of parliament for a
year now we voted on dozens of things
you know the budget welfare shop opening
hours the trade union bill absolutely
none of that is coming from Brussels
between fifteen and fifty percent of
British laws according to the house of
commons library in 2010 Oh their origin
to Brussels I don't see that I mean you
may see our budget but those are the
figures from your house of commons
library so for over the last year budget
welfare trade union bill all these bills
that have come through it's our budget
this is a sovereign parliament dealing
with government legislation that's come
from a sovereign British government yes
there is some legislation that comes
from Brussels between order for seven
fifty percent I that may well be what's
written on in the house of commons
library but my I'm is pretty good it's
pretty good as what i'm sharing with you
is my experience over the last year that
that's simply and that there's a big
debate about okay but you don't rub up
against a Brussels because you you
approve of the EU I don't rub up against
Brussels because I'm a British MP vote
in a sovereign British Parliament and
Wales is getting plenty and Wales is
where you have your constituencies
getting plenty of money out of the EU
but there are other parts of the UK that
aren't well the regional development
funds exist in order to create a
balanced and cohesive model across the
whole of the European Union and as we
know Wales is one of the most
economically challenged regions of the
UK that's why i support the regional
development funding because it actually
helps to you know a chain is only as
strong as its weakest link you're near
behind that the regional development
funding is the balance that up a union
that fails to respect individual
governments whose institutions no longer
command respect in member states where
the majority of Europeans no longer feel
their voices heard and you want to
shackle Britain to that indefinitely I
actually feel I mean I've been those are
criticisms that come from the President
of the European Commission I felices
Jean told young kim says that about his
own organisation he might as well be
working for for the leaf campaign monday
no i have been working in and around the
EU institutions for many many years and
following with great interest i did my
masters in european studies at the
college of europe i have never seen such
a nationally driven EU as what we have
now in fact the member states are
playing a much more influential role in
taking the EU forward but they're losing
little make a lot of the Commission I
was taking a back seat it hasn't maybe
why mr. Claus isn't happy that's what he
says we are losing economic clout in a
very visible way with the low birth rate
we're no longer respected in our
countries when we emphasize the need to
give priority to the EU one of the
reasons that European citizens stepping
away from the European project is that
we're interfering in too many domains of
their private lives hardly a ringing
endorsement of his own European Union is
it look that nobody is saying that the
EU is perfect this is a long way from
perfect this is unreformed would
probably apply that critique to a lot of
national government the semi-formal I
would certainly apply to our British
government now which i think is doing an
appalling a bad job of running the
country the democracies all over the
world are facing major challenges but my
question you're on the same side
this girl you're campaigning on the same
side and yet and yet you're so divided
that campaigns are so divided how do you
expect to unify the country if you can't
even unify the your campaigns actually
the remain campaign I feel is very very
United has been I've shared a platform
for example at a rally on Saturday with
Paddy Ashdown and also with a member of
applied company the Welsh Nationalist
Party and it was there was a really
great sense that we're in this together
and whilst we have our differences
politically we are united in the view
that Britain is stronger in you and John
even United with a leader of the Labour
Party Jeremy Corbyn I I mean you've
criticized him you actually contributed
nothing to party unity by stabbing
Corbin in the front and publicly
questioning his ability to lead the
party didn't you when did I do that you
said this in March and Huffington Post
you said the big question is when people
look at him do they see somebody who
could be the next prime minister of the
united kingdom hardly a ringing
endorsement at the same time as you've
been touting Angela Eagle a member of
the Shadow Cabinet calling her a great
leader look I questioning his
credentials in public you're stabbing
him in the front aren't you I think that
the question that I asked as a question
should be asked about any leader you
know is it a it's a question we should
be asking for example about any of the
potential candidates for leadership for
the conservative but you weren't asking
that restaurant or eagle were you come
on I mean be straight here you can't
stand the man and you don't think he's
gonna be a leader look Jeremy is the
leader of our party you don't think I'm
winning election date dude leaders are
judged by their results and the results
haven't been good you set standards for
him and he didn't meet them you wanted
gains in England you lost 18 seats in
England you wanted to come at least
second in Scotland you actually came
third behind the conservative which
given their record in Scotland is quite
a feat isn't it with the leg a disaster
for you the Labour Party is facing major
challenges we've got to get our story
right we've got to connect with the
British people again in a way that's
really relevant if the Chairman Corbin
isn't connecting you see we results like
that he's not connecting we've got a
long way to go we've got a long way to
go and it's a steep hill to climb and
he's not the right person to take that
well as I say
lead as a judge by the results it's
early day I notice you're not giving him
an endorsement here I'm giving you
plenty of opportunity to give him one
but your declining that I've been elec
I've been elected to represent the
people in my constituency you are facing
major challenges and many of those
challenges are caused by this appalling
Lee bad conservative government so i
will hold any leader of the Labour Party
to the benchmark that we need to be
delivering and we need to be winning and
I'm not going to and by criticizing him
in public you criticized him for not
doing enough to to back the romaine camp
you even said that's rather insulting
you to him that he should roll up his
sleeves like the Prime Minister I he
would have enjoyed that look I feel it
he would have enjoyed I think that we
should be treating this campaign for
this referendum as the most important
campaign in a generation in my view we
should be out there every single day in
factories in businesses in schools in
hospitals on trains wherever it you need
to be making the case so he has really
done must stay Josiah te you're
disappointed the you trade unions also
i'll be i would have liked to see Jeremy
I'm disappointed with I would have liked
to see him out there on the stone that's
disappointing I disappointed look I mean
I I'm not going to get emotional about
it I'm a social was where are you
discipline pleased or disappointed eyes
appointed I would have liked to see him
out on the stump every day as if this
were a short campaign in a general
election and there's still time we can
still do that we can still absolutely
make it clear to the British people that
we are one hundred percent were ninety
percent of the parliamentary Labour
Party ninety percent of Labor MPs are
fully signed up to the remain campaign
with far more United than any other
party on this and it is worrying if
people out there don't worry if we leave
Earth in your view doesn't play his part
there's been accusations of a lot of
hype by both campaigns you've been part
of this hyper mature in a way in April
you wrote brexit would be a betrayal of
the moral political and economic
principles that have underpinned
Britain's post-war journey let me get
this straight reasserting the primacy of
the British
Parliament in British affairs is a
betrayal of moral and political
principles the point I was making in
that article is we've been on a journey
since the Second World War where we've
integrated with Europe whilst keeping
the balance right with the Commonwealth
and the United it's done but this is a
tragic journey you're talking about a
betrayal of British values if people
vote to leave if people vote want to
increase their sovereignty get back the
right to make their own laws British
laws for British people well let's sir
look at that word sovereignty in my view
leaving the EU would fundamentally
weaken our sovereignty this is a
dangerous and uncertain world you pull
up the drawbridge and float off into the
mid-atlantic your sovereignty is deeply
weakened by that move that's why it
would be a betrayal I am presenting the
currency of British courts is is is a
betrayal well the primacy of British
courts is not in question the Earl it is
because they can be overruled by the
European Court of Justice certain in
certain areas of EU legislation if
you're going to make this system work if
you're gonna make a European system work
you need European institutions you need
and European law is the law the first
instance in this country the law of
first instance and people want to change
it we've been in New you for 43 years
and it's done us pretty well we've seen
growth we've seen stability we've seen
security we've seen peace you in order
to get you need to give a little bit to
get something back I see sovereignty
like a Boomer you throw it out there you
pull a little bit and more comes back to
you and you end up actually being
stronger through the partnerships
through the pooling of sovereignty yes
that means compromise sometimes that
means negotiation but we're we're we're
adults we should be living in an adult
world and working with this in a way
which is ensuring that we make a
patriotic case for the you what I am
what about stopping contributions to a
wasteful bureaucracy that consistently
fails to clean up the perennial fraud
and mismanagement of its finances what
about that well 55,000 civil servants in
the EU 60,000 civil servants in the city
of Birmingham so the idea that we've got
some kind of huge bureaucracy in
Brussels it's the absolute yeah but
60,000 60,000 bureaucrats in where did
you serve in burning mmm then they're
not wasting 6.3 billion dollar billion
euros in a year which is what the court
of Auditors said last November that the
Commission had done cited 6.3 billion
euros that had been misspent 2014-2015
Birmingham bureaucrats aren't doing that
the EU bureaucrats are oh that's huge
wastage is it that's unacceptable the
challenges with the accounting or around
administrative errors in member states
the members the the budgets are devolved
to the Member States the way that
they're dispersed and implement it is
where there are challenges and there are
some member states that have not done as
well as they should be in spending EU
money but it's not money that's being
spent by the Commission it's money once
they've divided up the EU funds it goes
to the Member States and in some cases
they're not doing the job that they
should be doing but there are 28 there
are 0 D investigators and they have had
for decades and we keep on getting these
results the point where the courts
president vithika there as said last
November we cannot afford to do business
as usual this is business as usual
wastage of an order of 6.3 billion euros
in a single year my point on this is
that the member states have got to get
the house in order and what we need to
do is move away from this constant
narrative of scapegoating and
denigrating the EU and this courage from
there auditing watchdog sure this isn't
your denigrating this is fact be 6 p.m.
3 billion euro but it you don't seem to
regard this is very important that I do
very very important any penny of
taxpayers money is very important but
this is about the Member States john
told you go says he's doing his best to
save money save money by wasting 6.3
billion at least look I mean we have an
EU budget and as we've discussed in
Wales that EU budget I think it's been
very well on some very important
infrastructure and economic development
projects but in other countries when it
gets to that country it isn't always
dealt with in the right way and the e
use the ordered EU auditors job is to
play the central coordinating role on
the checking and on the auditing but the
challenge with the
and the disbursement of the money is
that the member state well whoever is
responsibility is that doing a lousy job
in some of the Member States it is
definitely and the e use profligate
enlargement programs are costing an
enormous amount of money that's
disappearing down a black hole you take
the Balkans investment for instance take
the investment in Albania pouring money
into a country whose own prime minister
says that it is the most corrupt justice
system in the world 2014-2020 649
million euros of EU money part of which
contributed by Britain why should they
pour money into this black hole which is
characterized by trafficking in people
fraud on a grand scale trafficking arms
trafficking drugs and some of the most
violent organized crime in Europe today
why I might pour money into this wastage
what I mean what we know is with the
former Soviet countries in Eastern Bloc
is that they've come from a deeply
problematic past and one of the great
tributes to the European Union is
because of its soft power because of its
power of attraction it has helped those
countries to change to harmonize to move
to democracy rule of law but they're not
positioning to a market economy they're
not moving albania shows no sign of
movement in 2011 Europol said albanian
language gangs pose one of the biggest
problems they are notorious for their
use of extreme violence and you know how
Brussels rewarded them for that they
cancelled the need to give them visas to
get into you upset open the door up to
massive organized crime walking straight
through the door into the rest of Europe
how does that contribute to our security
I'm you know Albania is coming from a
place where it was a basket case you
know under people like in varrock sir
and that what at what an appalling so my
OK or take history to this they have
violence if you want to solve the
problems that are on your doorstep
you've got two choices you either think
you can pull up the drawbridge and float
off into the mid-atlantic or you can
engage and try and solve those problems
and i think the history of enlargement
is look where we've come i mean you know
when i was a teenager the idea
that I could even ever travel to
somewhere like Poland and the Czech
Republic was off the cards then the the
wall came down and the European Union
played an absolutely critical role in
building peace stability and the
transition to a market economy democracy
and the rule of law and because I am
gangs or if you arrangement they're
trafficking European people they're
trafficking in guns they're trafficking
in drugs and the European Union has made
it much easier for them to do that by
opening the doors not even requiring
visas look at Kosovo for instance I mean
Kosovo may be years away from membership
of the EU houses the largest EU foreign
mission bar none it's become a hotbed
for radical Islamists as new up Times
pointed out last month extremist clerics
and secretive associations funded by
Saudis and others have transformed a
once tolerant Muslim society into a
front of extremism and somehow the EU
with the largest mission that it has a
broad didn't seem to notice that
brilliant is that well I mean we're
ilion we obviously brilliant home gold
and guess what the reward was earlier
this month month ago previous no visa
travel anymore there is a huge challenge
with places like Kosovo and out
basically just a huge channels lovely
political speak but this is a disaster
it being allowed to unfold in the middle
of Europe and envelop all the other
European countries I mean I don't I just
don't accept that analysis of what's
going on there's there's a problem there
that you know there are always going to
be criminals and they're always going to
be bad people running around do is
getting worse listen to the report
justice and Home Affairs cooperation the
European Arrest Warrant the cooperation
that goes on between the five eyes and
the intelligence services the way in
which the EU integrates our economy so
that we've got a strong and stable
trust-based alliance those are the
things that we need to have in place if
we're going to date and the other
question for me is how would the UK
leaving the you help any of this stuff
we know that whenever Europe sneezes the
UK gets a cold whether it's in the EU or
not surely our history must teach us
that and if we want to be influencing
shaping agendas using arm superb
Diplomatic Service exhort was exerting
fresh and I hope one day with a Labor
Prime Minister in Brussels doing that
then we've got to stay in we've got to
be at the table europe according to
Europol is facing its biggest terror
threat in more than a decade and it
doesn't have the means to do it mayor of
Antwerp recently said that the waiver
Brussels doesn't do anything about
terrorism this is the mayor event were
you have the EU zone counterterrorism
coordinator jilda karakov warning of
more attacks if Europe doesn't start
sharing more information they said they
were going to share more information out
of the shaft ER the Shirley abdur
attacks they said they were going to
share more information after Brussels
they've been saying they'll set up a
passenger record information system for
years but they haven't done it why not
that and you think this makes us more
secure this is a huge danger to Britain
isn't it what's very important to bear
in mind if you take the 77 attacks here
or the batter client acts in in Paris
they were perpetrated by citizens of
those countries so the first thing I'd
say is it's not connected to free
movement of people because if you've got
citizens of your own countries that's a
problem of integration not of
immigration my other view is that I
think if there are mad people out there
who want to do bad things they're going
to do it whether or not the Schengen
zone exists but you've got I agree on
counterterrorism coordinator says the
system isn't fit for purpose then we got
to fix it I mean you could try to fix it
for years well but does that mean you
give up I mean you if they're artists a
major security is more important the
security in Britain is more important
than tying yourself to an organization
that doesn't know how to manage it I am
absolutely convinced that whether or not
we're in the you we will face these
security challenges and being in the EU
makes them far easier to tackle because
you've got the institutional framework
in place where you can work with your
partners work across the five eyes work
across police cooperation get those and
it say that but the improvement is one
counterterrorism coordinate is saying it
doesn't work
warning darkly since we'll have cyber
security issues we'll have people going
in all directions and the number will be
such that working nationally or
bilaterally with no one in the center to
coordinate I think we will miss
something no one in the center to
coordinate and you say this is a safe
system and you're glad we're alive with
it in Britain Britain is a lot I'm
saying that there's room for improvement
and clearly the system needs to work
better what we have is a mismatch
between massive improvements in
communication between people and it's
easier to get from one place to another
you got everything from budget airlines
to the internet who have revolutionised
the way that we work with each other
both in terms of business and leisure
those systems that those new
technologies have shot ahead of nation
states and national government and our
systems are trying to catch up and and
that mismatch between what's happening
out there on the streets and what is
happening in terms of our authorities in
the way that they cope with it both in
terms of governments regulating
international business and in terms of
security agencies dealing with some of
these security threats that gap needs to
be closed and it's a work in progress
and I'm not at all saying that it's
perfect but there is nothing that the UK
leaving would improve that situation
quite the opposite this this centerpiece
of their security which is supposed to
be the Schengen information system
there's no proper guidance about what
should even put on it there's no
requirement there's no nobody's it
forced to put any information on do you
know how many names are on the string
and information system I'm sure you're
going to tell me just 8,000 that's it
and that's the centerpiece of supposedly
European security not very impressive is
it one of the challenges of the EU is
always faced is that member states are
the building blocks of the EU and
they're holding on to their sovereignty
I can understand why they're doing that
what 42 year of terrorism why should you
understand why they do good question
good question but it's about national
political cultures it's about histories
it's about this sense that you're
leaders constantly feel they've got to
go to Brussels and win something and
often winning a short-term victory I
mean our prime minister david cameron is
in many ways been one of the worst
exponents of this he did things like
pull his party out of the european
centre and conservative group in the
european parliament which I think
dramatically did reduce the UK's
influence he did it for short-term gain
within his own party short term / all
right but I wondered we need leaders who
have a strategic view of what it means
to create clearly you don't seem to have
them in Europe by the Steven cadet
thanks very much for being on confidence
ank you very much
you